[Music]
let's talk about the bridge it's such a
good show
and uh and it's such a great idea
for a show
because uh your character is searching
for a serial killer
and because this killing takes place
exactly on the border between the united
states and mexico you have to work with
a mexican a mexican detective and and it
just makes everything twice as
complicated and and the story is twice
as rich i think yes yes and also my
character has asperger's yes which is uh
on the spectrum of you know autism so um
they work together and it's it's pretty
crazy like their cultural differences
are just insane and and you were telling
me that you uh mostly you shoot here in
los angeles but you wanted to do
research
so you yourself decided one day i'm
going to go to to warriors you went to
juarez yeah we were shooting a little
bit um for the pilot in juarez in el
paso sorry so you know it's right there
and then i decided to walk over with one
of my
showrunners and spent the day which was
fun it's not it's not as dangerous as
ever i mean i'm sure it is
but it's not as dangerous as i thought
it was going to be you said that like
you're encouraging me not to go i'd
stand out
looking for a blow or hookers
no i have no
[Laughter]
no i have not
right
not to juarez
right
so you'd be okay yeah i'd be fine your
character carries a gun and i know that
i've i've talked to a lot of actors
i know i'd be one i'm not an actor but
were i an actor i'd really like carrying
a gun because i get that i've just got
that kid thing if i like to pretend
maybe it's a boy thing you you carry a
gun and you use a gun well on the show
but you i'm not very good at it you know
again maybe it's because i'm not
american but i've i don't like guns i
don't like anything that has to do with
guns i don't like people being shot in
shows like i'd rather watch
you know a sex scene than
well i agree with you
[Applause]
this
[Applause]
but anyway
um so yeah i'm not very i'm not very
good with the guns i i forever dropped
him i nearly killed a new york times
reporter who was on set the very first
day of the show you know i was trying to
look all professional and tell her about
my character and
i fumbled with my holster and and and
the gun just dropped on her head which
as you can imagine didn't go well how'd
that review come out yeah exactly the
review was was not so great for me you
know why they hired her for this yeah
it's a very intense show is this the
kind of show that you would watch
yourself at home yes absolutely yeah you
would watch the bridge but is it the
kind of tv that you watch in general do
you watch those kinds of shows
like breaking bad you know house of
cards
uh i like uh i like breaking bad i think
is absolutely my favorite show
i don't watch i know a lot of people
watch reality shows and i never
i never got into reality shows like i i
don't think there's one reality show
that i watch i watch honey boo boo
that's my it's like i do it's like crack
to me it's like watching star wars you
know it's it's so wait a minute okay
it's like watching crack it's like star
wars uh
you really honey boo boo well it's just
it's so crazy to me because maybe again
because i'm not american like that part
of america is just so foreign to me and
i can't stop watching it's like
do you watch it i've seen yes i i've
watched some of it yes i got i got to
say i feel like they are actually
happier than any of us they love each
other like they make fun of each other
remember that the pig living with them
and then the 13 year old got hit by
lightning and now everybody thinks she's
crazy and all she wanted for her 13th
birthday was go to this place and buy
you know where you know if you if you if
you managed to eat a five pound burger
you get a 200
and nobody was able to do it in you know
50 years and that's all she wanted for a
birthday so you're saying you watch this
and you think that these people are
happier i just it's just i don't know
there's something about it that's very
endearing to me it's funny that you like
you're like i like breaking bad and
honey boo-boo
i don't know where those two come
together oh
star wars
funny boo-boo does sometimes seem like
the cantina
with all the weird characters yeah